I want to jump to the store from the
post millennial
Donald Trump will be arrested by Fannie
Willis on Thursday in Atlanta he says
I'll be going to Atlanta Georgia on
Thursday to be arrested by a radical
left district attorney
and in the context of all of this uh uh
agenda 2030 type stuff more so how
Democratic politicians agree with
climate lockdown ideas and want to stop
climate change those kinds of things
the future I Envision with an
unobstructed Donald Trump is secure
borders
you having a job somewhere factories
coming back and uh kind of the older way
of doing things
what Democrats want and I mean it's
literally I'm not going to use any
euphemisms or conspiracies like
literally when they talk about climate
change they want a reduction in fossil
fuels they don't want factories they
want to Outsource they want you to I
don't know I don't want to say oh
nothing and be happy because that's more
World economic forum but they very much
want you to live in your cubicle box and
just be told what to do and do what you
want and many of the people in cities
seem to be completely okay with it
Donald Trump is an inversion of that and
for that he is their biggest threat
so of course Trump will be arrested but
we do have more news on this a second
Georgia lawmaker is seeking the
impeachment of Rogue district attorney
Fanny Willis so with everything we've
talked about so far in terms of degrowth
and agenda 2030 climate lockdowns
coveted lockdowns may be coming back it
is not a foregone conclusion there is a
very clear path to Victory and I think
it is the obvious path to Victor and I
think it is the likely path to Victory I
think it is a likely outcome Donald
Trump only lost in 2020 by a margin of
about 42 000 votes in three states
there's I I think it is unlikely they
screw it up this time Trump has already
said we need a bad harvesting operation
there are already already being moves
made there's more activism ramping up
and the Democrats don't have the
advantage of hard lockdowns they need a
hundred Scott presslars is what they
need and they have to get rid of they
need to get rid of Ronald McDonald's
that's one thing that I wanted to ask
you what is your take on Ronald McDaniel
putting me on the spot I know well I
like to call her Ronda Romney McDaniel
don't forget that because so okay that's
all I need to know honestly you just
literally given me your ability you
buried the lead no I think the RNC loves
to fundraise a bunch of money off of
well-meaning Patriots use it to use
really really cushy uh you know Retreats
at five star resorts and do absolutely
nothing and I think they spit in the
face and they're laughing behind the
backs of people like Scott Pressler
um people who are actually doing the
work and I don't think anyone should
give any money to the RNC and look no
further than the Antics they've been up
to with this whole debate that's
happening tomorrow trying to get Trump
to join in on it Rana is a is a joke she
spends I think a lot of the money on let
fillers
I'm not gonna touch that one do you do
you why do you feel like Trump got
behind her
or what it what do you think he was
thinking because I think that was
probably one of the worst things that he
did since he's been out of office is
actually putting his support behind Ron
McDaniel she's the in my opinion she's
the biggest person at fault for allowing
the Democrats to just outperform them to
out politic them you know it's like on
the the ground game that the Republicans
had was such an embarrassment compared
to the Democrats and the Democrats run
rings around them and it's Ronald
McDonald fault she was in charge so like
where's the accountability you know and
what are they actually doing to make
sure that it doesn't happen again
because if you re like I really do think
that the biggest culprit for why Donald
Trump didn't didn't isn't in the in the
white house now is Ron McDaniels in the
RNC I think it's twofold I think in
addition to the RNC just being like the
abysmal little sister of the DNC
couldn't even compete if they if they
wanted to I also think the DNC has sort
of an extension of an app that is the
groups like the center for Tech and
Civic life right the Zuckerberg type
groups and we just because we are the
right we don't have that and I would
argue that independent of the DNC I
think those so-called non-profits that
really shady dark money apparatus
is what allowed Democrats to win more so
I I I and you're not Ronan I'm not
trying to push you on the spot so but
why do you think it is that like I'm
definitely not wrong I know so I'm not
trying I'm not trying to put you on the
spot but like so then why do you think
it is that like nothing was done like
why is it that that she
like because because the things
Democrats have have a history of having
a better ground game and because of the
fact that they tend to Cluster in urban
areas it's easier for them to do things
like get you know ballot Harvest why is
it that Rona hasn't you know nobody has
thought about the fact that that this is
you know this is the way things are like
why didn't why weren't they prepared I
you know I don't I don't know no I I
think you know it's the same question
and the same answer and the same logical
just anger that you get when you ask why
House Republicans aren't doing anything
anything really meaningful when it comes
to the hunter Biden investigation to
impeaching Joe Biden to these covered
mandates to defunding the government and
I think the issue is it's exactly and
precisely people like Rana who really to
their their Court yeah maybe they're
Republican but they're not really
conservative again I was going to say
Trump supporters Maga type but I know
that for some people that might not
necessarily be what they identify with
but I think these are people who are
very okay with the staff status quo
because the status quo means that they
retain their power and I don't really
think Rana cares if Republicans lose
elections I don't really I just think
she wants to retain her position Phil
would anybody go watch the Harlem
Globetrotters if the Washington generals
won
they'd be I would buy tickets to the
next game
it would be interesting yeah to be
completely honest but uh I I I just I
hate to break this to you Phil but the
generals they're meant to lose I mean I
you know I I wish I wish that we had a
legitimate opposition party how about
that it looked like we were turning
point USA Charlie Kirk I think they were
who was it Harmony Dylan running against
the Army was I thought don't forget no
oh they both work yes the energy in the
room was electrifying and turning point
when we were talking about it harm meat
was there and I thought like of course
it's like confirmation bias I was like
she's definitely gonna win with this
kind of support it was only like a
thousand people you know and of course
you get caught up in your own smell but
like uh then I I mean that's the that's
the Lively Republican basis Charlie Kirk
and turning point like that's young
people yeah
yeah so I just don't know why I mean I
don't know if there's malfeasance behind
the scenes and that's why Rhonda took it
if Ron is just more popular on the
global stage so that's why she got it
did they vote well I also think the RNC
election rate's not actually Americans
voting it's people within the confines
of the RNC and I think what you're
talking about right the disconnection or
rather just connects between the
Grassroots activist actual Maga type
people and the selection of Rana and
it's sort of like the same phenomenon
phenomenon I would argue with Trump in
2016 or that was the first time there
was a candidate who actually appealed to
the actual Republican voting base as
opposed to the more Elite you know donor
class and I think unfortunately the RNC
I mean there's a reason it has the
reputation it does for the most part and
there are some RNC members who are you
know more populous who are you know come
on war room all the time and are always
willing and down to slam Rana but I
think unfortunately most of the members
of the RNC because think about how you
get to be in the RNC you don't go get to
be a member of the RNC or the Committee
Member committee woman if you're like a
hardcore outspoken populist type you
know doing hardcore Trump activism they
were against Trump in 2016. so I think
you have a lot of holdovers there who
again not that it's about Trump as a
person it's about more than that it's
about the Strand the stripe of the
Republican party and the voters who who
get behind him and I think the Rana
Romney McDaniels of the world the elite
Republican the country club Republican
class has done everything in their power
to suppress and quash that stripe of
conservatism
oh well that makes sense
you know Vivek I was listening to him
ramaswamy on Sean Ryan's podcast last
night and he was saying how like it's
really not about Republicans versus
Democrats it's about the I guess you'd
call it the administrative class versus
everybody else and they've got this
stupid lock and he's like just you gotta
fire them you've got to cancel the FBI
and musician a lot of the the people
into other departments and things we
should not have a political class
I agree it's weird to me that there's a
political class that should not exist
people who are born and bred and
educated for the sole purpose of being
in charge of people makes no sense right
I'm sorry that's how it maybe used to be
with Lords and stuff like that but now
this is supposed to be a country for
oven by the people which means it's
supposed to be a person who is running
for office here's why here's my
experience instead
perhaps only because of the natural uh
Tendencies of man people who Carpenters
plumbers electricians taxi drivers you
name it astronauts it's like look I
don't want to deal with these policies
can we just get someone else to do it
and that's how it happened in the
federal government it came from laziness
according to Vivek when he was on our
show He was discussing this about a
month ago that the people in Congress
just didn't want to do the work anymore
so they outsourced it to the uh what do
you call it the Federal Reserve yeah
they like they create these external
things to do their work that they should
be doing that's because if they take
votes and they're if they vote on the
record they have to answer to their
constituents if they pass the buck to
someone else I didn't do it so when they
go back to win Congress people go back
to their their uh their areas
um you know they can be like oh well you
know I tried and I told you I wouldn't
I've tried to but you know it didn't
work so because this is how it goes now
it's all about getting the the less
they're responsible for the happier they
are because it's more likely they'll win
their the re they'll win re-election so
taking responsibility for the actions is
a huge part of why they Outsource it or
why they've been trying to that's why
they did it with with Donald Trump with
the uh or not I'm sorry not Donald Trump
with uh George Bush when he came to the
Iraq War and stuff they gave him the
authorization for use of force they're
supposed to declare war they didn't
actually that's what makes the Iraq War
illegal is the Congress doesn't have the
authority to give the president the
authority to make war the president can
react so that your president can send
the Marine Corps to like you know to
save American lives or whatever but the
president can't conduct War the Congress
is supposed to is supposed to declare
war if we go to war when Congress gave
the president that power they didn't
have the power to do that so that means
that the president didn't have the power
because Congress didn't have the power
to give the president the power so when
the president ordered all the troops
into Iraq it was illegal because he
didn't have the legal Authority the uh
the authorization for the use the force
is an unconstitutional document it was
an unconstitutional law so is the
Federal Reserve Act also
unconstitutional legal the Federal
Reserve Act is unconstitutional there
was an amendment that I believe was was
uh improperly
um
improperly ratified that was for the the
Federal Reserve but the Federal Reserve
there there are people that will make
the argument that it is unconstitutional
because it is not outlined in the in the
Constitution
um but there are also people that are
going to say that the necessary and
proper clause uh allows for it thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time